explíquenos cómo funciona el mercado
energético europeo y si con estos
cambios se podrá reducir el precio de la
energía
si actualmente el mercado energético
europeo funciona más un libre mercado o
sea el precio al por mayor es
determinado por el mercado actualmente
por la demanda que es muy fuerte y la
mayor parte del consumo es de energía
producida a través de centrales a gas
sin embargo muchos países como grecia de
francia y españa- producen mucho dirigía
desde fuentes digamos renovar de nuevo
renovables no y también en energía
nuclear que es mucho más barata que la
energía costosa del gas ya que la idea
de la reforma de díaz era que la energía
que es producida con fuentes baratas
sería controlada al precio final sería
controlado para el comprador de salirse
si tras este anuncio de la unión europea
el precio de la energía a un año vista
en alemania se ha reducido en torno a la
mitad podría ser esto un indicativo de
que el mercado energético europeo sufre
una burbuja especulativa
no no no es una burbuja porque no hay
una apuesta que precios aumenten o
aumenten o menos no aquí hay un problema
geopolítico en juego un problema de
logística también o sea el objetivo es
bajar inmediatamente el precio a las
industrias sobre todo y también al
consumidor es una medida de corto plazo
a largo plazo explicaría una pérdida de
competitividad para los generadores de
energía barata porque en realidad no
quiere proponer la unión europea es una
represión de sus lucros actuales o sea
hoy pueden vender a 13 mercados que
mucho más elevado
a causará gran demanda por gas pero si
esto sigue a la larga estas empresas
perderían entonces esta oportunidad de
lucro le dirían capacidad competitiva
para hacer mejores inversiones y mejorar
su capacidad también de
infraestructura
y la comisión europea ha anunciado hoy
también que estudia limitar el precio no
solo del gas sino de las energías
renovables vista la emergencia climática
que ya estamos viviendo puede la
unióneuropea estar buscando no sólo
reformas sino un cambio hacia un mercado
alternativo
esto ya sería algo mucho más avanzado la
idea es como esas energías energías
renovables son más baratas a la
generación eléctrica partir esas
energías es más barata entonces la unión
europea- aprovecharía ese hecho para
entonces controlar el precio de la
electricidad generada por esas fuentes
de energía
o sea aprovechar que uno puede manipular
el precio sin necesariamente
y practicar sus personas etcétera sin
embargo esta seña e imponer una
subjetividad a esos generadores de luz